est-ce que tu parlais français à la
maison non j'ai pas parler français à la
maison
1 ma mère parle français
mon père parlait pas français juste
parce que mon père mes deux parents en
fait tu fais partie de la génération
perdue c'est ce qu'en dit il c'est la
génération des personnes ou leurs
parents parlait pas français à eux parce
que comme mon grand père paternel lui il
était puni des frappes été battu à
l'école par ces enseignantes parce qu'il
pouvait pas parler anglais
ce à cause qui pouvait pas parler
anglais et puis ils te frapper part de
ces enseignantes hélas pas parler
français avec mon père nous mettons une
maison sur mon père fait partie de cette
génération mais c'est drôle que les
enfants de la génération perdue et
veulent aujourd'hui revenir à ce moi je
trouve que c'est pas grave je trouve que
c'est quelqu'un c'était quelque chose
qui était volée de notre expérience
1 c'était le gouvernement louisiane et
avec la loi qui dise l instruction
l'école pouvait être juste en anglais
puis dans une génération
ça commençait à disparaître ça
commençait à prendre quelque chose
sow comme je le mérite
je veux ses mots c'est ma culture pas
comme si c'était prix de mes parents moi
je voulais reprendre et quel âge est ce
que tu avais quand tu as décidé que
c'était dommage que c'était quelque
chose qu'on a volé à toi toi et à ta
génération
j'avais quand même 19 ans et à suis allé
faire un l'immersion en nouvelle écosse
et j'ai vu que tout le monde parlait
français dans cette région et j'ai dit
et puis aux autres ils avaient tous des
mêmes noms de tous les gens que je
connaissais
chez nous il y avait des brousses heures
puis de brou trop de leblanc plein
d'envié mais pourquoi nous autres on
parle pas français
tous les joueurs comme eux parce qu'on
vous dit beaucoup du français en
louisiane que il est en train de mourir
ben moi je suis en vie et je parle
français
si le français n'est pas en train de
mourir parce que moi je suis 7 et moi je
parle français et moi je suis moi je
suis je vis c'est ça c'est pas en train
de mourir